تعرضت عده مواقع تابعه لاحزاب كرديه
معارضه لايران داخل اراضي اقليم كردستان
الى قصف صاروخيا وطائرات مسيره الهجمات
استهدفت مقرات الحزب الديمقراطيه
لكردستاني في قضاء الكويسينق واسفره عن
مقتل اثنين من مقاتلي الحزب اضافه الى
اصابه ثمانيه اخرين ايضا كان هناك استهداف
لمقرات حزب كولا في منطقتي اذا كان باربيل
واسفره عن اضرار ماديا بالتضامن مع ذلك
الشهادات منطقه زرقويس في محافظه
السليمانيه ايضا قصفا بطائرات مسيره طوال
اليوم الحكومه الايرانيه اعلنت مسؤوليتها
اتجاه هذه الهجمات التي وصفتها بانها
استهدفت مقررات تابعه
لارهابيين وجماعات
هددوا ان ايران اما حكومه اقليم كردستان
فقد مددت بهذه الهجمات واعتبرتها تجاوزا
لسياده اراضي الاقليمي والعراق هذه
الهجمات تتكرر من قبل ايران على مواقع
احزاب ايرانيه داخل اراضي اقليمي كردستان
وقد شهد شهره سبتمبر في نهايته عده هجمات
على معظم
المعارضه لايران داخل اراضي اقليم كردستان
السير حكيم الجزيره كويس شارقه اربيل